Ego is the enemy.
Can you take that too far?
I can joke about myself all day and be okay.
But also I don't want coworkers not to take me seriously.
So that's actually kind of two questions.
It's talking about ego and the soccer about joking around.
Right.
Those are,
those are two different things.
A little bit like self deprecating.
Yeah.
And so can you,
can you be too humble and put your ego in so much?
Check that it hurts you.
Yes.
Actually you can,
you know,
hey echo,
how's it going?
I'm in charge.
Um,
I'm really horrible at this.
I just don't know what I'm doing right.
That's not good.
You know,
it's like I said to the Marine lieutenant,
right.
Am I tell them to go and into check in and say,
hey guys,
I,
you know,
I just don't,
I just got here,
just got out of the basic school.
I don't know anything really.
Do you want to call that guy?
No,
that's the one I'm talking about suits or can you be overly humble?
Yes.
Like I said,
it's okay to admit that you don't know everything,
but that doesn't mean don't be well prepared.
That doesn't mean don't be confident that you can figure things out.
That doesn't mean you can't ask good questions.
Right?
It doesn't mean that you don't report in without knowing the nomenclature and
the fundamentals.
Right.
That's gonna.
You know,
hey Jocko just checked in.
But he knows what our mission's been.
He knows what our mission statement is.
He knows how our basic processes,
he already looked at all that.
He knows everyone's name.
Yeah,
I'm prepared.
So that's what you want to be.
That's not saying,
I have no idea what I'm doing right now.
I just got here.
No,
no,
that's not what we're talking about.
So don't be overly humble.
Most people,
the reason I talk about the other one of be humble all the time,
it's because most people tend towards letting their ego be inflated.
That's what most people tend towards.
So I tend to talk more about,
hey,
keep your ego in check when you're checking.
Cause most people that are so scared of looking bad they'd say,
well I know how to do this.
I've never seen it before.
I know how to do that.
You've never seen it before and you're going to look stupid.
Hey guys,
a [inaudible] been put in charge of this.
I know you guys been doing it for awhile.
Looking forward to learning from you on how you execute it and,
and driving forward and keeping kicking ass in this mission.
Does anyone get mad at that?
No.
It,
that's a lot different than,
hey guys,
I have no idea what's happening.
That's too much.
Yeah.
So don't go there and be humble,
but not,
not passive.
Put your ego in check,
but don't turn into a baby.
Work the desk.
Uh,
the second part of this as a question about joking around too much and that's,
you know,
that's different from too much ego and absolutely you can joke around too much.
Now,
of course.
And we've talked about this,
a good team and a good leader.
They're having fun,
they're having fun with everything that you're doing.
And I always had fun.
I always had fun.
I still fun all the time.
I'm having fun.
But if all you do is joke around all the time,
but then when it comes time for the joke to be over,
people won't take you seriously,
so that will be problematic.
You know,
I had a rule that was no joking on the radios.
Right.
So if you were on a radio,
you weren't allowed to take make jokes.
No joking on the radio.
And what's cool about,
because you know,
in tasking to bruiser when I was a platoon commander,
when I was assistant platoon commander,
we had fun all the time.
We laughed,
we joked,
we had a blast with everything we did.
No joking on the radio.
You see what I'm saying?
That was a law.
No joking on the radio.
And what was good about it was as I think back to that,
what that translated to was we're not joking around in the field and that
expanded,
look,
when we're briefing,
we're not joking around.
It was a very clear distinction,
of course.
Did people have,
did things happen out in the field?
Sometimes we're like,
oh my God,
this is hilarious.
Of course that happened,
but the general,
99% of the time,
95% of the time was,
hey,
we're in the field,
we're working.
We are serious.
That's the priority.
Did we have fun in the field?
Yes.
Did I laugh in the field?
Yes,
but the priority and this norm was we are going,
we are serious and we are.
That's the priority.
So don't joke so much that you
don't get taken seriously.
One time I was with a senior ranking officer,
a flag officer,
meaning an officer with stars,
and we went to go brief.
I wasn't attached to this unit,
but then they went to go brief this unit or we went to go receive a brief from a
unit and in the brief,
in a PowerPoint side,
these guys hadn't put a slide in.
That was an inappropriate slide and it was a crude joke and it was really funny.
I thought it was really funny,
you know?
I was like,
oh,
that's pretty funny that these guys did that yogurt.
I saw the slide.
They had it up there and it was completely inappropriate and andF and vulgar.
Right.
That's what it was.
They didn't know this general at all.
And he was a very straight laced guy and didn't appreciate that kind of humor
and they,
they,
they had like the welcome slide.
The next slide that came up was this inappropriate vulgar slide.
It was,
it was,
it was inappropriate.
I'll leave it at that.
And,
and you know,
it was like there was a chuckle in the room and at the same time there was
nothing but silence in the room.
You could feel the discomfort.
And,
and since like I said,
I thought it was funny and I knew it wasn't going to go over well as soon as I
sought out,
Ooh,
that's not good.
And the reason I'm telling this big long story is because I have another rule.
Don't put jokes into your slides in PowerPoint.
No jokes.
Because you can,
you can articulate the joke cause you can feel the out and see what's going on.
You can get it.
Get a taste.
You can get a feel for them if you,
if you walk in,
if they would have had a chance,
if I could have said freeze the first slides up,
you've met the general here for for five minutes,
do you want to remove that side?
They'd be like,
oh,
absolutely.
Let's get it out of there.
Because they could see that he was a serious guy and,
and not,
you know,
one to be that that wants to be seen.
That kind of thing.
It didn't take,
wasn't hard.
It was pretty easy book to read,
but you don't have that opportunity.
There was no,
hold on.
We're going to delete this slide.
Nope.
There it was.
Boom.
Welcome.
It was the,
it was after the slide of,
you know,
this is where we are was the welcome slide.
And I said,
oh,
so no joking on the radio.
No joking in your slides,
keep your slides clean and,
and the,
the risk benefit.
You tell a good joke,
hey,
that's great.
You get,
you know,
two credits.
If you're joke is bad and considered inappropriate,
it's negative 39 and not worth it.
Yeah.
It's not worth it.
And again,
I'm all about,
you know,
you,
you want to have fun when you're briefing.
You want people to be entertained and have fun,
but you don't want to have inappropriate stuff.
No.
Yeah.
So that's that for both these,
for both these things.
Am I joking too much or am I being too serious?
Am I,
you know,
as my ego too big or am I being too humble?
You,
it's a balance.
It's a dichotomy of leadership and you've got to find the right spot in the
middle and you've got to check yourself and you've got to,
you know,
any of your team is joking when they shouldn't be joking.
Guess what?
You're leading them the wrong direction.
If your team is somber and doesn't have any spirit,
you're not having good enough time.
So you gotta find the balance there.
Same thing with ego.
You know,
are people talking with you and communicating with you and being open with you
and telling you when they disagree with things or is no one talking to you?
Because if that's the case,
your ego's so big that they don't want to talk to you.
So find the dichotomy,
leadership,
find the balance between those two.
Dang,
that's a good one.
If,
if they're,
um,
if they're not talking to you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause you know,
Holland at work,
you're talking with your friends,
you know,
then somebody comes,
that person comes who you're like,
oh yeah,
for whatever reason you're not necessarily talking about them or nothing,
but they come in your car,
you've got to stop your conversation,
you know?
Yeah.
That's like a little indicator,
you know,
if you roll up to,
you see people across the room talking and you're like,
hey,
that looks like a cool conversation or whatever.
I'm going to go say hi to Paul,
whatever.
And you go and they stopped talking and they stopped laughing.
They just stopped talking and they give you like small talk or whatever.
That's,
that's the indicator.
Yeah.
It's an indicator.
It could be actually either one of those too.
If people are having a good time and you walk in and they stop laughing.
Oh.
So you say,
okay,
and if you walk in and they're having a conversation that they don't,
they just don't want to talk to you,
they're probably,
they probably don't like your big ego that's slapping him in the face.
Okay.
Put your ego in check.